Good afternoon. Welcome to the very short NCBI minute  about PubMed and ClinicalTrials.
My name is Ben Busby, I am the genomics outreach coordinator for NCBI.
I will present this webinar. I have with me Peter Cooper and Kathi Canese
from the NCBI  education group and PubMed, respectively, who can help answer your questions.
Many researchers, clinicians, and medical librarians are very interested ClinicalTrials.gov,
which is a registry of clinical trials.
What I want to show you today, is a very quick and easy way
to filter your PubMed results by those that are also in clinical trials.gov.
If we were to search for cancer and G protein in PubMed we would find about 25,000 results.
One could look for article types under ClinicalTrial.  Also you could go to our advanced search page.
And there are many options there. On which you can filter.
However, I would like to show you an even easier way to get into that information today.
From individual abstracts we have added ClinicalTrials.gov numbers and there's a direct link right at the bottom of the PubMed abstract as you can see here.
But a very easy way to find things that are in ClinicalTrials.gov, is to put ClinicalTrials.gov  directly in the PubMed search box.
However, the really neat thing is that you can combine ClinicalTrials.gov with a particular type of cancer, and G proteins,
to get a very narrowed down view of this. The reason we made the webinar
is a lot of people ask us questions related to this topic. If you have other questions that you are interested in finding out about, please check out our webinars page
under the archived webinars and courses tab, there are many many webinars that you can check out.
And also there's a lot of documentation for many of our resources. That said, if you are interested in seeing a particular topic for a webinar,
please email us at webinars@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov.
With that we would like to take any questions that you may have.
The first question I have I would like to address to Kathi Canese. The question is, have you gone backwards in time to add clinical trials numbers to abstracts in PubMed.
We actually have exposed any abstract or citation I should say that had a secondary ID,
clinical trial number, but was not included in the abstract. We are now exposing that information
so that you don't have to open up the secondary source or MeSH section on an abstract. We're moving that information directly under the abstract and we are adding the link directly to ClinicalTrials.gov.
Thanks Kathi. In a related question someone asked how far back will ClinicalTrials at the end of  and the abstracts go?
I don't know. We can run a search right now, i’m not certain. If you go to PubMed and type in, sorry on second here,
if we  type in clinicaltrials.gov into the search bar and press search you will see in the right-hand discovery column results by year.
We have information back to 2000. There are two citations in Results by year diagram you can see the individual accounts broken down by year.
Thank you, Kathi. One more related question. Will adding ClinicalTrials.gov just take you to PubMed abstracts  that have NCT number. I think you partially answered this question.
Right. If you just search for ClinicalTrials.gov we're looking for that phrase in the title in the abstract or in the secondary source ID field.
So if that phrase doesn't exist, the information will not be there. However, there is a filter that you can use and that is clinicaltrialsgov, no period, and bracket it with filter or subset,
And you will be able to see all of the links that are curated between the clinical trials.gov database and PubMed.
If you type in clinicaltrialsgov no period, and press enter, you will retrieve 209,000 citations.
When you click on an abstract for those citations you'll see a link out button that will go to the clinical trials database. Unfortunately those icons are sometimes delayed by 24 or 48 hours. You will probably want to skip to the next two or three pages.
So I will check on that filter. You should be able to see the link out icon that goes directly to the clinical trials.gov database.
A lot of the other questions are tangentially related. We will go ahead and respond to those off-line. If there are novel questions, we will go ahead and put the answers on the FTP site.
I would like to thank Kathy for her time. I guess the one thing I want to reiterate is if you used the filter, there will be indexed way farther back
than if you use the clinical trials.gov search. I hope that this has been very useful to you. If you have further questions,
please feel free to email webinars@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov and we will be happy to try to answer them.
Thank you and have a great day. We hope to see you at future NCBI webinars.